[Music]
how many bathrooms do you have in this
mansion there are 14 bathroom
14 bathroom everybody means 14 bathrooms
right well it's been a year since our
special correspondent Antonio sabato jr.
got the only peek at the construction
going on inside the home of Real
Housewife of OSI Heather Dubrow is all
finished now but the only room she is
allowing people inside of is her closet
which actually looks a lot more like a
department store egl lines Bryce ander
got the exclusive tour this is one of
those rooms where it's something special
caught my eye and I needed to have it I
did not say no from the glitter carpet
to the chandeliers the mom of four
spared no expense for her estimated 400
square foot hideaway this is my girl
cave it's it's the place where you know
I put two chairs so we can hang out dran
we can drink there's a champagne
doorbell yep press a button for a bubbly
on-demand
I like everything behind glass so that
way it doesn't get dusty because one of
my pet peeves is when you pull something
out and you have dust on the hanger so I
don't like that so everything is
protected everything includes at least
60 designer scarves 50 pairs of jeans
more than 150 pairs of shoes and 150
handbags this is bag land um pretty much
tuna
lots of Chanel pretty much everything's
out how much and where is it from
I think I paid $28 from and it's from
Zara bargain item so this is a little
leather Chanel jacket yeah and look like
leather I know but feel it how long have
you had it like 15 years what's the
oldest piece in here may alright now we
have the Big Island we can destroy all
your glittery things I had to measure
all of my things and make sure that
everyone had a little compartment that
would fit there's a keypad to this
center island and it has two different
codes so one code for one side one code
the other and with so many expensive
items it's no surprise Heather's big on
security there's padlocks on both doors
deadbolts with code
but only I know so literally no one
could come in no kids allowed no less
than I invited in if you're invited in
you're invited in and if you're not
you're not
oh so can't get it with a champagne in
the club I'm putting a fridge in my
closet
tonight Yeah right so you can actually
watch at their insider closet drinking
champagne each week she hosts a new
episode of Heather's closet every
Wednesday on YouTube
[Music]